er macht seit jahren öffentlich was
andere gern verbergen würden verstöße
gegen den tierschutz in schlachthöfen
stellen und laboren friedrich müller
sieht sich als ermittler sein verein
heißt so gut tierschutz nun erinnert
sich an einen fall in sachsen-anhalt
magath da durch die stallungen es ist ja
dunkel man hat nachtsichtgerät und
sieht dann halt einen kadaver nach den
anderen da liegen
teilweise schon total verwest
mumifiziert bei manchen tropfte noch das
blut raus dazwischen verletzte tiere
also das war ein eindruck der der halt
mal wirklich gezeigt hat was für
probleme in der industrie vorherrschen
und wie man die auf die spitze treiben
kann
münz verein schickte die bilder an
journalisten vor ort
wir bekamen eine mail von einem
tierschutzverein der soko tierschutz
heißt von dem hatte ich zuvor nie gehört
es gebe da ein fall im landkreis stendal
wo gegen den tierschutz verstoßen würde
und weil das zu unserer journalistischen
sorgfaltspflicht gehört wandte ich mich
an die besitzer des betriebes die waren
bereit sich mit mir noch am selben
nachmittag zu treffen
die besitzer der milchviehanlage sagten
einerseits sein dass gar nicht aufnahmen
aus ihren stallungen
andererseits schien in die aufnahmen an
sich auch nochmal manipuliert
doch der fälschungs vorwurf entpuppte
sich als ausrede die aufnahmen dagegen
zeigten die grausame realität im stall
die offenbar keiner behörde keinen
amtstierarzt aufgefallen waren
so was wahr ist unvorstellbar dass man
im prinzip von einem toten rind zum
nächsten gehen kann
das ist ja das schreckliche bei den
versteckten kameras kann man ja nicht
direkt eingreifen
die bilder zeigen der automatische
coachee bereist ein kalb mit
die kutsche sucht halt mit dem maul
irgendwie ihr kälbchen bei sich zu
behalten und dieses kalb ist
höchstwahrscheinlich in der güllegrube
geändert wurde dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde
erlassen gegen den amtstierarzt
der ist letztlich zum ende des jahres
von seinem posten zurückgetreten
das ist totales behörden versagen dieser
stall hätte innerhalb von ein zwei tagen
dicht gemacht werden können das
beweismaterial war eindeutig die
behörden hatten alle informationen und
die behörden haben auch die
möglichkeiten so was zu tun das
veterinäramt ist nicht zahnlos und
es hat dann im endeffekt zwei jahre
gedauert bis dieser stall dann langsam
abgewickelt werden konnte
ich bin jetzt seit 27 jahren im
tierschutz und seit 27 jahren begleitet
mich die gleichen probleme verstümmelte
hühner verstümmelte schweine seien in
ihren käfigen hühner in ihren käfigen
und die agrarindustrie schafft immer
wieder die politik selbst wenn es mal
versucht völlig auszumanövrieren
immer wieder sind tierschützer unterwegs
und filmen missstände in ställen
einzelfälle oder ein flächendeckendes
problem fest steht die amtlichen stall
kontrollen sind lückenhaft bis ein
betrieb kontrolliert wird vergehen oft
jahre
manchmal jahrzehnte so etwa im agrarland
niedersachsen
21 jahre und in bayern sogar mehr als 48
jahre
dieser mythos von das wird ja alles
kontrolliert er ist der ist halt so
nicht nicht haltbar im schnitt werden
was alle zehn 20 30 jahre je nach
bundesland unterschiedlich stelle
überhaupt nur kontrolliert also wir
kriegen zum größten teil gar nicht mit
was da läuft
die bundesregierung hatte eine
kommission eingesetzt experten sollten
die probleme in der landwirtschaft klar
benennen und lösungen aufzeigen die
sogenannte borchert kommission bekam
parteiübergreifend lob für ihre arbeit
das ergebnis eindeutig zitat es zeigt
sich ein erheblicher handlungsbedarf zur
verbesserung des tierwohl niveaus in der
nutztierhaltung
selbst in den ställen in denen alle
gesetze eingehalten werden kann es den
tieren schlecht gehen zitat
aber auch dort wo spezifische haltungs
vorschriften vorliegen und eingehalten
werden bestehen teilweise erhebliche
tierwohl defizite
irgendwo in brandenburg ein
schweineaufzuchtbetrieb
einem reizwort bekommen wir diese
aufnahmen aus einem stall zugespielt
wenige wochen alt
der anlage waren viele sauen mit
blutigen wunden an den klauen und diese
wunden wann teilweise auch schon
entzündet und man hat gesehen dass die
nicht erst seit gestern bestehen diese
aufnahmen zeigen auch einen ferkel wurf
im stall die tiere sind mitten in der
nacht sich selbst überlassen in den
letzten jahrzehnten wurden die sauen so
gezüchtet dass sie immer mehr ferkel zur
welt bringen und eine folge davon ist
dass viele schwache werke und kleine
ferkel auch zur welt kommen die es
vielleicht nicht schaffen sich direkt
aus der fruchtblase zu befreien die es
nicht schaffen die zitzen zu erreichen
ohne hilfe sterben einige werke bereits
kurz nach der geburt probleme in der
tierhaltung
die die bald regieren wollen haben
bisher dazu wenig gesagt im sondierungs
papier nur zwei sätze zitat wir wollen
die bäuerinnen und bauern darin
unterstützen die nutztierhaltung
tiergerecht umzubauen für transparenz
beim einkaufen soll eine haltungs
kennzeichnung sorgen
gero hocker ist im landwirtschafts team
für die fdp bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen dabei ein großer
streitpunkt woher soll das geld kommen
für mehr tierwohl bisher haben die
liberalen eine sogenannte tierwohl
abgabe stets abgelehnt also ein paar
cent mehr pro kilo fleisch für mehr
tierschutz im stall bisher nicht mit der
fdp das hört sich inzwischen anders an
es kann im grunde nur eine tiroler
abgabe seien die zweckgebunden ist und
ich glaube wir müssen dahin dass
tatsächlich am ende die standards die
gefordert werden auch einen
transparenten aber dann auch einen
angemessenen preis an der ladentheke
hält der auch bezahlt wird das wäre die
musterlösung die wir hinkriegen müssen
in den nächsten vier jahre bisher kann
allerdings kein verbraucher erkennen
woher sein schweinefleisch stammt auch
das will die fdp mit den neuen partnern
ändern es muss für den verbraucher quasi
auf einen blick erkenntlich sein woher
auch die vorprodukte in dem endprodukt
stammen ansonsten werden nationale
alleingänge nicht dazu führen dass wir
mehr tierwohl erreichen vielen
tierschützern geht das nicht weit genug
für sie ist nur der verzicht auf fleisch
konsequent wenn man sich anschaut was
erlaubt ist was legal ist diese tiere
haben nichts für ein gutes leben sie
haben nur schmerzen leid und elend und
wir sind es gewohnt fleisch zu essen
nichts zu essen eier zu essen aber
genauso kann man sich auch was anderes
gewöhnt
klaus kaiser ist sich sicher würstchen
müssen nicht aus fleisch sein sein
familienbetrieb südlich von stuttgart
ist marktführer in europa für bio vegane
produkte
dazu gehören zum beispiel die wiener aus
seitan ich habe schon immer alles
fremdartige viel viel interessanter
geworden als die eingefahrenen wege
seite ist dass wir um die starke
bereinigt zurückbleiben die sehnen
deswegen sagen die chinesen traditionell
dazu auch ein sinn das heißt szenen des
mails
geisa verzichtet seit
1979 auf fleisch bin ich ganz ehrlich
sein soll
ich habe immer den
fleischgenuss vermisst
es ist eine riesenherausforderung
diesen an sich relativ geschmacks armen
seiten so hinzunehmen dass er eine
fleisch assoziationen erweckt
immer mehr junge menschen verzichten auf
fleisch und so stieg der umsatz von
fleischersatz produkten 2020 auf 375
millionen euro
trotzdem eine nische fleisch bleibt
beliebt umsatz 2020 mehr als 38
milliarden euro
es wird produziert in stellen die
fabriken gleichen mit millionen tieren
eine neue bundesregierung hat es in der
hand ob das wohl der tiere in zukunft
eine größere rolle spielt als bisher
[Musik]